first for people that don't know what
pops are do you mind explaining what
they are sure pops are privately owned
public spaces plazas you seen outside at
all office buildings and what happens is
in New York City if you put in one of
these plazas
you can build a taller bill you'll get
what's called a zoning variance from
city you can build a much taller
building than you could otherwise so for
landlord of say Donald Trump this is
very attractive because instead of
building 40 storey buddy Mike about 60
it took me six visits to Trump Tower to
get into the garden through the door and
we will see signs for Trump bar the
Trump cafe the Trump grill there's
nothing about this garden the only sign
that I could find it mentions this
gardens above the elevator to get past
this elevate into this elevator you have
to get past a guard the fact that it was
so neglected really surprised me and I
thought no why are they missing this
business opportunity
I remember these got a thought I thought
over here I'm gonna hide it in my jacket
which has a hole in it I'm also wearing
my black power fist so I think we get
into the Trump Tower karats yeah yeah
yeah
like I do
all right here we go
it's very small it's got a tree and some
hostas and a garbage can and a bench to
sit on
I mean clearly we're not the only one
who got in
okay we gotta go to the fifth line
everything everyone is more more
exclusive
how you working is this the only garden
that one and this one that's it okay Oh
special thanks i shal not really okay oh
thanks
there's a there's a fountain there that
seems to be always turned off they don't
want to spend money on the water I guess
like an inventory of everything is here
love we're doing our job it's really
efficient it 9r extreme for small trees
Tainan 48 seats total 64 fixie 84
moveable chairs 21 tables should we
count the chairs yeah we should
that my kattiline for work
and stores
I mean I'm straining hearing I feel like
I feel like if Donald Trump word I have
a garden this is what it look what look
like this is pretty appropriate so I
imagine that it's clean and it would be
reporter Erin Elsie saying like the kind
of a myth
like you have this be
and they can potentially
customers
this is Donald Trump you know all about
making the most of this business
opportunities date they built the space
they they're fulfilling the letter of
their contract and that's as much as
they care to do
I felt Nellie I felt unwanted but
neither wanted either so there really
wasn't any sort of
feel dirty